RECENTLY JEFF DUNCAN, THE
REPUBLICAN LT GOVERNOR OF GEORGIA,
SAYS HERSCHEL WALKER WAS GRANTED
A MULLIGAN IN THE RUNOFF, AN
EXTRA FEW WEEKS TO CONVINCE THE
DEMOCR
DEMOCRATS TO CHANGE THEIR MINDS.
SOUTH CAROLINA DEMOCRATIC STATE
LAWMAKER, BAKARI SELLERS.
REALLY SIX DAYS LEFT, DO YOU
THINK THAT HERSCHEL WALKER HAS
CONVINCED ENOUGH GEORGIANS TO
SEND HIM TO THE SENATE?
>> WELL, THERE'S A SERIOUS
IMBALANCE OF ENERGY RIGHT NOW.
THE WARNOCK CAMPAIGN SEEMS TO BE
GAINING SEEM AND MOMENTUM.
AND EVERY TIME YOU TURN ON THE
TV, THERE'S AN AD RUNNING.
IT'S NOT NECESSARILY THE WALKER
SIDE.
I THINK YOU MENTIONED THERE WAS
A BRIEF FIVE-DAY PERIOD WHERE HE
WAS ABSENT FROM THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL.
THE ADS DON'T SEEM TO BE AS
NUMEROUS.
AND THERE DOES NOT FEEL THERE'S
A TON OF ENERGY.
THIS CAME DOWN TO THE SUBURBS.
CAN HE CONVENTION THE 200,000
PEOPLE THAT VOTED FOR BRIAN KEMP
BUT VOTED FOR RAPHAEL WARNOCK TO
SHOW UP AND CLICK ON HIS NAME.
AND IT DOESN'T FEEL LIKE THAT'S
HAPPENING.
>> SO, YOU TOLD CNN IN THE FALL
THAT WALKER DIDN'T DO ENOUGH TO
GET YOUR RESPECT OR YOUR VOTE IN
NOVEMBER.
WILL YOU BE VOTING FOR HIM NEXT
TUESDAY?
>> Reporter: SHOWED UP TO VOTE
THIS MORNING.
I WAS ONE OF THOSE FOLKS WHO GOT
IN LINE AND SPENT ABOUT AN HOUR
WAITING.
IT WAS THE MOST DISAPPOINTING
BALLOT I'VE EVER STARED AT IN MY
ENTIRE LIFE SINCE I STARTED
VOTING.
I HAD TWO CANDIDATES THAT I JUST
COULDN'T FIND ANYTHING THAT MADE
SENSE FOR ME TO PUT MY VOTE
BEHIND.
SO, I WALKED OUT OF THAT BALLOT
BOX SHOWING UP TO VOTE, BUT NOT
VOTING FOR EITHER ONE OF THEM.
>> SO, YOU DIDN'T VOTE.
DIANNE GALLAGHER REPORTING WE'RE
SEEING RECORD BREAKING EARLY
VOTE NUMBERS IN GEORGIA.
SO, DO YOU THINK THAT'S GOOD
NEWS FOR THE DEMOCRATIC CAMPAIGN
HERE OR BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT A RUNOFF HERE AND A REALLY
COMPRESSED SCHEDULE, DOES THAT
CONVENTIONAL WISDOM GET THROWN
OUT OF THE WINDOW?
>> NO, UNDOUBTEDLY THAT'S GOOD
NEWS FOR DEMOCRATS.
WE'VE SEEN THE TRENDS.
INSTEAD OF HAVING THESE POLLING
DATA WHERE REPUBLICANS FLOOD THE
ZONE WITH JUST POOR POLLS, WHAT
WE SEE NOW IS THAT WE ACTUALLY
HAVE DATA WE CAN LOOK AT.
THAT'S THE EARLY VOTING NUMBERS,
WHERE THEY COME FROM IN GEORGIA.
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR DUNCAN IS
PROBABLY BETTER THAN I AT
TELLING YOU WHAT IT MEANS WHEN
SOMEBODY VOTES IN RICHMOND
COUNTY VERSUS FULTON COUNTY OR
DEKALB COUNTY, ET CETERA.
BUT I DO BELIEVE THAT WHAT WE'RE
SEEING IS THAT DEMOCRATS ARE
COMING OUT.
I THINK RAPHAEL WARNOCK IS
RUNNING THE PITCH PERFECT
CAMPAIGN FOR THE MOMENT.
AND LET ME ALSO SAY THIS, THIS
IS SOMEWHAT CONTENTIOUS FOR
PEOPLE WHO MAY NOT BE FAMILIAR
CULTURALLY WITH WHAT I'M ABOUT
TO SAY.
BUT THERE IS A GREAT DEAL OF
RESENTMENT BY BLACK VOTERS FOR
HERSCHEL WALKER.
THERE ARE MANY BLACK VOTERS WHO
YOU SPEAK TO WHO SIMPLY SAY THAT
HE DOES NOT SPEAK OR REPRESENT
US VERY WELL AT ALL, FROM THE
ALLEGATIONS OF ABUSE, FROM BEING
INARTICULATE, FOR NOT
UNDERSTANDING BASIC CONCEPTS.
AND THEREFORE, WE DO NOT WANT
HIM TO REPRESENT US ON THE WORLD
STAGE AS A UNITED STATES SENATOR
IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
I EXPECT YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE A
LARGE NUMBER OF BLACK VOTERS
COME OUT, AGAIN, FOR RAPHAEL
WARNOCK, OVERCOMING THE FATIGUE,
AND A GREAT DEAL OF YOUNG VOTERS
COME OUT FOR RAPHAEL WARNOCK,
OVERCOMING THE FATIGUE AS WELL.
>> I WANT TO GO BACK TO YOUR
DECISION NOT TO CAST A VOTE IN
THIS RUNOFF ELECTION.
WAS YOUR VOTE GETTABLE BY
HERSCHEL WALKER IN THIS RUNOFF?
IS THERE SOMETHING HE COULD HAVE
DONE?
OR WHAT IS IT THAT HE COULD HAVE
DONE TO GET YOUR VOTE TODAY?
>> I THINK I'M IN THE SAME SPOT
THAT HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
REPUBLICANS AND MILLIONS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY, WE JUST WANT REAL
LEADERSHIP TO NAVIGATE US
THROUGH THE MESS AND MIRE OF
WHAT WE'RE SEEING PLAY OUT IN
WASHINGTON, D.C.
THERE'S A COUPLE EASY PIECE OF
LOW LYING FRUIT.
WHEN NICK FUENTES DID WHAT HE
DID WITH DONALD TRUMP AND TOOK
THE DINNER MEETING, PUSH BACK ON
THAT INSTEAD OF HITTING THE MUTE
BUTTON.
THOSE ARE WAYS TO CONVINCE THE
MEDIA YOU'RE NOT DONALD TRUMP'S
PUPPET.
YOU WANTED TO BE A U.S. SENATOR
WHO WANTED TO DO IMPORTANT
THINGS AND LEAD USING BIG IDEAS.
THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
AND THAT'S DISAPPOINTING.
AND I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
FINGER POINTING STARTING TO
HAPPEN.
THIS IS A LOT LIKE A LOCKER ROOM
AFTER A COUPLE LOSING SEASONS OR
A COUPLE OF BIG LOSSES.
PEOPLE ARE STARTING TO POINT
FINGERS, AND THERE NEEDS TO BE A
NEW DIRECTION FOR THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
THIS IS GOING TO BE ONE OF THOSE
MOMENTS IN TIME WHERE WE POINT
AS A CATALYST THAT ALLOWED US TO
FIND REAL CANDIDATES TO STAND UP
AND WIN THESE CASES.
>> SO, BAKARI, ONE OF THE THINGS
YOU ARE HEARING FROM
REPUBLICANS, THE SENATORS WHO
ARE GOING TO CAMPAIGN FOR
HERSCHEL WALKER IN GEORGIA IS,
YOU KNOW, KEEP US AT 50/50.
DON'T GIVE THE DEMOCRATS 51
BECAUSE IT HELPS US IN COMMITTEE
STRENGTH.
IS COMMITTEE STRENGTH SORT OF A
SALIENT CAMPAIGN PITCH TO
VOTERS, REPUBLICAN OR DEMOCRATS?
>> WELL, LOOK, I WANT RAPHAEL
WARNOCK TO WIN THIS ELECTION,
AND MY MAMA ALWAYS WOULD TELL ME
TO LEAVE WELL ENOUGH ALONE.
AND THERE HAS BEEN NO BETTER
MESSAGE THAN THAT OF LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR DUNCAN ON WHY RAPHAEL
WARNOCK SHOULD PROBABLY BE THE
NEXT UNITED STATES SENATOR, THE
INABILITY FOR HERSCHEL WALKER TO
ACTUALLY SERVE.
LET ME JUST SAY THAT THE CLOSING
MESSAGE FOR HERSCHEL WALKER IS
GOD KNOWS WHAT.
HE'S ILL FITTED, HE'S ILL
EQUIPPED TO BE A UNITED STATES
SENATOR.
AND I THINK PEOPLE ARE
RECOGNIZING THAT.
YOU ALSO HAVE THE LEVEL OF
EXHAUSTION THAT GEORGIA VOTERS
HAVE.
BUT, YOU KNOW, LET'S ADD THIS
UP.
LET'S LOOK AT IT IN THE BALANCE
AND THE TOTALITY OF WHAT IT IS.
TOMORROW, YOU HAVE BARACK OBAMA,
WHO IS, I WOULD SAY, ARGUABLY
THE MOST POPULAR EITHER CURRENT
ELECTED OR FORMER ELECTED
OFFICIAL ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL
CAMPAIGNING FOR RAPHAEL WARNOCK,
WHEREAS YOU HAVE DONALD TRUMP
DOING A TELECONFERENCE.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THAT IS.
A TELE-RALLY FOR HERSCHEL
WALKER.
AND I THINK THAT ACTUALLY GOES
TO THE POINT OF MOMENTUM.
AND RAPHAEL WARNOCK HAS THE
MOMENTUM GOING INTO THIS.
51/49 FOR DEMOCRATS IS A HUGE
ADVANTAGE, AND WE KNOW THAT.
I THINK PEOPLE KNOW THAT.
BUT YOU DON'T WANT TO GO INTO
SOMEBODY'S HOUSEHOLD SAYING,
PLEASE GIVE ME 51 VOTES FOR
COMMITTEE ASSIGNMENTS.
I THINK GEOFF DUNCAN AND I WOULD
BOTH AGREE THINGS LIKE
INFLATION, IMMIGRATION, CRIME,
ET CETERA ARE THE NUMBER ONE
ISSUES.
IT AIN'T GIVE ME THE NUMBER OF
VOTES I NEED SO I CAN GET THIS
FLUSH ASSIGNMENT ON THIS.
>> I THINK WE JUST MADE CNN
HISTORY WHERE PANELISTS DEFERRED
THE ANSWER BACK TO THE OTHER
GUEST HERE.
GEOFF DUNCAN, BAKARI SELLERS, I
APPRECIATE IT.